surprise c'est pas vrai baird attendez
et vous n'avez rien à faire ici j'ai
tout arrêté
ok bon je recommence j'ai tout arrêté
stop a pu une petite interview
non je crois que j'ai beaucoup mieux
elle est mon corps je veux sentir ton
poids glisser entre nos mains délicates
ok c'est dans un autre pot ton somers
rue j'arrête préférés petit matin quand
remonte le moral est remonté en le
maintenant minutes c'est pas des
conneries je peux prévoir dès qu'il
neige pourquoi mon chien vrai foutoir où
goûteux bien votre tête
détendez-vous et resterez l'année non on
vous doit une fière chandelle tc passer
leur bac s c'est ma caisse ça ma caisse
au nom aussi vous presque 9